hé là, il a entendu que tu venais
comment tu t'appelles, je cesse de
voir quelque chose de drôle Je suis Carter Wilson
majordome en chef ne t'inquiète pas pour Big Mo
derrière toi frère Steve portefeuille avant
même que tu ne le saches il n'y a rien le
maire ici  son nom est James
Holloway il est mon commandant en second J
Jackie Robinson avec moi pourquoi ne serres-tu pas la
main de l'homme en premier où tu
commences à poser des questions difficiles comme
ça Je ne sais pas où la masse
devant laquelle je suis ressemble encore au jury  à partir de
là, tout va bien, pasig prêt à me donner le
jouet, mais il l'a fait, ce sont les Dodgers deux,
je pourrais peut-être répondre à cette question
si Carl ici arrête de courir sa vilaine
bouche